[Music]
come on so Google Play we love games we
want games to be engaging we want game
developers to be successful we put them
through a boot camp and they get
feedback from leading industry experts
mentor and they continue to receive
support long after they graduate from
the program the moment when we were
selected with just scrolling through all
the names and saying there's our name
based on it and says then name came up
both of us we got up we ran to the edge
of the room then came back and gave each
other a huge high-five I think it's
gonna be super awesome considering all
the people from the gaming industry
would be there there's a lot in store
for all the developers to learn over
here
[Music]
it's also been really really great like
we've learned so much from all the
mentors even our fellow game developers
and Indies from along this region one of
my favorite things is the variety of
problems and issues and opportunities
that we get to deal with and help um if
you've gained so much from this industry
and from you know the people who helped
us it's time to give back to them the
best thing in the program the Mentors
I think mentors who knew the business
better than us who were able to state
hard truths that allowed us to change
our perspective the indigent side later
program have given me the confidence
that you know we can really make amazing
games it doesn't matter where you are in
the world and my friends and family are
definitely taking me more seriously than
what I doing more CSP 2019 I'm super
excited about seeing with these enemies
from hub with the new titles but also
the tools that we're developing I'm also
excited about the whole new batch
abilities helping them through the
process of launching titles and building
their game studios and seeing what we
can do within global stage
[Music]